welcome all back
to stokon x midwest and we
are now on the cusp of having our
experts panel and today on our panel
we have quite a few illustrious experts
and they are um
piotr uh san quits or you can call him
peter
he is a writer and a philosopher a
proponent of reformed socialism
author of a manual of reformed stoicism
how happiness writes pages or does it on
socialism
and artistic creativity and other things
and he is a member of the modern
stoicism team
peter stan quits then we have
thanks for having me sorry thank you
thank you
um next we have gregory lopez
he is the founder of the new york stokes
a co-founder and board member of the
stoke fellowship
co-author of a handbook for new stocks
and
is part of the modern stone stoicism
team
leadership he is gregory lopez
are you there greg i am here can you
hear me
yes great thanks for having me
um next we have matt vanetta he is the
author
of the beginner's guide to socialism and
a creator of the stoic
podcast good fortune his writings
focus on the daily application of stoke
philosophy
in the modern world matt vanetta
thanks for having me
next we have travis hume he is the
founder and the writer of the applying
stoicism social
media group thank you travis hume
are you there
i apologize can you hear me now yes
great
lots of mute buttons everywhere
next we have the uh our previous speaker
meredith koontz is a writer living in
northern california and the author of
the stoic
mom blog she's a mother of two daughters
and one she's not hanging out with her
family
or blogging she works full-time in the
field of science and technology
communications
meredith everyone
i usually pronounce it coons thank you
you're very close
um and finally and last but not least we
have
kai whiting he is a researcher and
lecturer
in sustainability and socialism based
at uc luvane in belgium he is the
co-author of the book
being better stoicism for a world worth
living in
and he tweets that at kaya whiting and
blogs over at stokekai.com
kai whiting hi it's great to see many
friends around here so i'm very it's
great company it's brilliant it's
fantastic i'm so happy to see
so many people in one place
so this is the panel at the moment
um and so i guess uh
because our questions haven't fully
arrived guys
please add some questions i can ask for
the the people here um
what was uh some of the uh
early things that brought you to
stoicism
hi uh really difficult
uh circumstances and uh not
really feeling as though you were in
full control of your emotions
or what brought me to uh solidism um
i preferred not to feel like sad
or like upset and uh i recently came off
the end of a
intro to philosophy class where i was
told that there was a philosophy out
there that actually
had you grapple with those emotions
effectively and i was like wow
and i decided to give it a shot and here
i am
some seven years later
um well we've got our first question
here uh what
are your favorite favorite daily
practices maybe uh
greg lopez could help with that
considering he's got this whole book
full of them
right i had to put them all down because
i can't answer that question um
so i guess i would probably say that my
personal favorite daily practice
fluctuates on where i'm at right now
right now i'm finding a lot of utility
and reminding myself of the role
of the role i'm playing at any given
moment um and what
and what role i occupy in order to
suggest my next action so when i'm
distracted at work i remind myself i'm a
worker now which suggests the next
action
of getting back to work um sometimes
when somebody wants my uh
tension in order to converse i can
switch like into a friend mode there
um and sometimes like if i get
interrupted i may get annoyed but then
i'm like i want to be a friend and so i
do that so i say keeping my role in mind
is the stoic practice that's helping me
the most right now
uh same question for anyone else
well yeah i can give uh i can give
slightly paradoxical answer to that
because i
uh as far as i understand myself i don't
have any
daily specific static practices which is
kind of a
may sound it may sound odd but the um
the the key thing here is that i'm as a
writer as a guy who
practices uh writing on stoicism i do
write a lot about stoicism and
not only on that and therefore in a way
writing not only on stoicism but writing
in general about philosophical topics
other than stoicism too
it is in a way uh an ex a spiritual
exercise uh
to me like in marcus aurelius and so on
uh and it doesn't have to necessarily
it can necessity it can uh
be writing on stylism or teaching on
stysis and i actually i like
i like saying that i feel uh i feel i'm
the best version of my style
of my stomach possibilities right after
i conclude
teaching a class on stoicism or doing a
war crop on stoicism
that's probably where i'm where i'm uh
where i'm at
at most but it doesn't have to be
statism
necessarily uh generally the act of
writing down things uh whatever the
as long as kind of philosophical it uh
it works quite well for me so
uh that's specifically stoic but in the
other sense
it is kind of a practice
i would say reading and writing are my
practices
um and that's one of the reasons i
started the stoic mom blog
is i just really wanted to have a more
regular practice of writing
about these ideas it helps me work
through my ideas
it helps me understand how they apply to
situations that i find myself in
and so i really advocate that and just
reading bits of
original text modern texts about
stoicism
you know helps me think about how can i
apply this to my everyday life
and then when i write about it i really
process it
and i think that helps
so we've got a question here from
uh rog veer i hope i'm pronouncing that
not totally horribly um what is the view
of ancient stoics on truth
is it that one should always speak truth
irrespective of a situation or is it
okay to circumvent
for say a greater good
that is understandably a really
difficult one
um as far as like speaking the truth
there are some stoic quotes that float
around
most often from marcus aurelius where he
says
specifically if it's not true um don't
say it if it's not right don't do it
probably paraphrasing that a little bit
um
he also mentions elsewhere that you
should try to get yourself in a state of
mind
where you are if somebody asks you a
question like what are you thinking
right now
you should be okay and ready to just
respond with what is
on your mind and not be ashamed of it to
get yourself in that kind of mental
state um
as far as speaking truth um irrespective
of like the situation
like to make sure like i understand what
the premise is is that it's
um not being afraid to speak the truth
um holding that to be of higher value
um and then possibly alluding to some
situations where
um speaking the truth might prevent
someone else from like
getting hurt or like inconvenienced or
like basically telling like a light
white lie
um that's that's one that i would have
to think about
um a little bit more really really
because like
if somebody's like do do i look fat
eats in these pants um
you don't necessarily have to be like
you know objectively speaking
yes you know you can you can work with
the person
um if it's to like preserve someone's
life
um i would say that there there could be
an argument made
um for the pers for the the stoic
concealing information to stop the other
person from getting hurt
but i have to think about that one for a
bit
i would turn the question on its head a
little bit and ask how sure are you that
you necessarily know the truth that
you're going to speak
i think one of the most valuable stoic
practices uh is to
kind of loosen one's own opinions and
views of things and so
it really depends on the circumstance if
you're of what the truth you're speaking
is so i'm not going to directly answer
the question however
there's the ancient stoics views on
actually having logic as a virtue
are laid out in diogenes laertes and he
speaks about logical virtues there
and some of those have to do with
loosening your opinions about things at
the end of the day so
one thing i would recommend is
questioning before speaking whether you
actually know
the truth that you're about to speak
so we've got a great question from steve
karafit
um so what is the biggest challenge for
the modern stoic movement today
the coronavirus i suppose
like for all of us yeah i also think
that there's this issue of
broicism some people call it i think
greg has used that term of
kind of almost um
fraternity brother stoicism i don't know
how to put it but
just the the concept that you know stoic
is here to sow a system is here
to be this life hack to make you super
masculine and
super macho and you know if you're not
like that then oh don't even bother
calling yourself stoic
um which really excludes women first of
all i find
and it's very biased so i think if that
part of the movement kind of co-opts
modern stoicism
we're in big trouble or at least out our
brand of modern socialism won't really
be heard because
i think there's a lot of marketing and
kind of uh
you know publicity that goes to that
maybe because a lot of people are
interested in that which is also fine
but
i i feel that there's a type of of stoic
modern stoic
uh philosophy and ideas that can really
help a lot more people
rather than that particular approach
can i add something down absolutely i
couldn't agree
more with uh meredith i think she's
absolutely right um
and i did talk about it in the
presentation where i think the biggest
challenge is that people say
that studies in statism is an
individualistic or individual pursuit
but if you know anything about spirits
which who was a student of zeno
he actually took socialism to sparta and
he used it to
work to teach clear men is the third
how to enact social economic and land
reforms so people think that story the
collection between stars and sparta's is
resilient
hard guy but it's actually the fact that
they
king cleo minis and his wife basically
invited
a historic to help them um bring about
quote-unquote justice or a fairer
spartan society
and i really think that we are losing
that in that i would say the
contemporary movement the other struggle
that
i see is the struggle between should we
have an agnostic or atheistic or
spiritual
kind of stereoism and i'm like i think
we can have a big enough tent
i think we can be a bit more neutral so
i think there's a struggle and sometimes
sometimes we
are quick to judge either way both kinds
it's not uh
it's not just individual camps that are
like that that's like oh if you're not
if you don't have this way of thinking
all that's a bit unscientific of you oh
if you're not
you know you're not spiritual that's a
bit um closed-minded of you so i think
that we
i think at the cohesion within all
contemporary stoics
including modern stories and needs to be
improved and i think these kind of
events are the way to do that because
it's
we have to be very careful i think
greg's actually absolutely right to ask
yourself questions about how much we
actually
know because sometimes we go about
including academics saying that we know
something
and that can be very very dangerous
merely for saying the same thing like
you know we need to be very careful
about how much in our own image we want
our kids to be
or historism to be right and i think
that's a real danger even my heart
you know to say something like yes i
think for example socialism should be
more
environmental but i could just be saying
that because that's my field so i think
we all have to be careful
all of us particularly though people
with public space to say what stoicism
is rather than what it can encompass
so we've got a question specifically for
matt vanetta
i like the theme of your podcast that
misfortune
born nobly is good fortune
um my question is do you have any advice
along these lines for dealing with
the pandemic
sure um
well i'm the pandemic has been
quite interesting just in how it
it lends itself very well to uh
to challenging our uh our stoicism and
how we
how much we want to really um
embody it in the fullness of our lives
right um
so um i mean the pandemic itself
uh challenges our views of
life and death um it challenges our
views of society um
um community uh very much so
uh and then challenges us in our own
lives some of us
like i have to go to work in public at
all times and some of us are
in our homes you know so uh there's
different
versions there so i'm trying to think
i'm saying this just uh
to think you know what's specific um
because it's everything it's hard it's
always hard for me to break it down to
one thing
um i would
say
to bring you know one of the things i've
been trying to work even harder on
myself on recently
is to bring stoicism back always to
virtue you would think that that would
be
key but i think it's really easy to um
to think about exercises to think about
quotes and so on and so forth and not to
truly bring it back to
the embodiment of virtue in your in your
own life
and um uh
the you know one of the big ones that
i'm thinking about
now because of the present moment not
just the pandemic
in my country but for others is is
justice
and i think the pandemic challenges
us to truly
think of ourselves as a part of
a of a greater whole of our local
community our family
and then of course widening uh that to
encompass all
all people and in this world um and
that we can use the pandemic and the
various challenges that come from it
uh to uh to focus
uh ourselves as as thinking about the
the bonds we have between ourselves and
other people
um so i i i feel that what i just said
is very vague
but um uh but yeah that's really
that's what i focus the most on right
now is is
um uh you know how does how does this
moment
uh remind me how interconnected i am
with others and and how that should
shape uh my my approach
uh to life does anyone else have some uh
quick thoughts to add
i do um i think
greg kitty on the head when he said that
what is your role
so if we think of our role for example
as a parent
then i would say in the pandemic is
about explaining to
your kids the situation as
you know concisely as you can without
worrying them depending on their age
and then concentrate on as a family how
you can work on it you know work through
it
what you can do as a as a historic in
all the roles that you have so
in my role it might be talking today and
saying well yes we do have a pandemic
but it's also a great opportunity
because for example
i wouldn't be able to go to milwaukee
right so the pandemic is actually
brought something really positive where
we have different people
throughout the entire world sitting
together in literally the same room
now that would be pandemic that would
not maybe have happened so
i kind of think that what can we see
positively
and how can that equip me in my role
rather than taking everything as a
negative but i think
greg would probably be give you a much
better or more concise answer than that
no i think you just spoke to what i was
going to say as well that it really
depends on what who you are and what you
particularly you're dealing with in the
pandemic so i think there's no answer to
this question epictetus uh
there's a discourse on giving stoic
advice and somebody
uh asked for advice he's like i'm not
gonna give advice because like what if
you
came to me and tried to write the name
dion down i could take your hand
physically
and move the pen or the stylus and
write it for you but then and you could
probably even practice that motion and
do it well but then somebody comes and
say hey write the name theon
you're going to be lost and so i think
that in terms of the specifics of what
to do
i'm not sure if that's as useful a
question to answer as to get the process
down and i think
kai explained very well about what the
process is thinking about your role
first
great what greg just said though did uh
didn't you think of one particularly
so um uh speaking of epictetus uh is
uh epiteutis said um that it is
impossible that happiness
and yearning for what is not present um
shall ever be united
uh right and um
the pandemic in particular uh in the
states were coming up upon
thanksgiving which was uh quite a
holiday for my family and we have
except for my my my immediate family my
daughter and my wife that we've
eliminated that there's no
going to friends or anything we had to
give that one up and we had hoped that
not been the case but
um you know the pandemic uh to bring
ourselves to focus on that which we
actually have and how we can be good
in that as opposed to letting the things
that
we could have had that have been lost um
take over our thoughts
uh i think is something that's a it's a
huge challenge
in life and then stoicism and is worth
reflecting on
thank you so uh we've got a question for
all
um i struggled from uh aaron macmillan i
struggle to feel
like a stoic i feel like someone who
studies stoicism
is that common
yes it is uh if i might very shortly uh
if i
i'm not sure if i understand the
question
properly but uh basically this is uh i
believe uh the feeling we
the sentiment we all have that no one
just as meredith said
there is no really aesthetic sage is a
bit of an idol or a construct or
or some idea we aspire to but there is
no way of
feeling fully sonically for prolonged
uh a period of time the best we can get
is uh if we uh sometimes manage to
we have this feeling that yeah something
happened and i dealt with that stoically
that this is a small success and i did
it well
and it was like in this or that
situation but to be a stoic
like in full hundred percent all over
the time it's just impossible and we
shouldn't we
shouldn't be concerned about that
because yeah we are we are all the same
in this regard i think
i want to say i completely agree with
what you just said and
i think um as i said you know we know we
acknowledge
we're not stoic stages for me i was
drawn to this
because of some of my own you know
issues or things that challenge me
personally
and so this is it's aspirational in many
ways like oh i wish i could be this way
i want
to be more like this i this is something
that can actually help
me personally and it really it really
does as i start to apply it even in
small ways
and those are just the small victories
when i see
okay i didn't get you know super
stressed about the fact that i couldn't
control that thing
or uh i was able to frame this in terms
of
uh justice and fairness instead of you
know me wanting what
you know was do me or something like all
those kinds of decisions that we have to
make on a regular basis i think it's
super important to remember that we're
all just doing the best we can and i
think to me that's like a very
fundamental part of
a stoic life philosophy we're just doing
the best we can
and this is a framework it's but it's an
excellent framework
and it's something where we can
constantly refer back to
am i examining my impressions am i am i
stopping before i just have a knee-jerk
reaction and every time i do that i
realize okay
that is a way i'm living a more stoic
life i
i didn't just allow myself to become you
know
super angry about this thing or
frustrated i was able to stop and
question that and kind of a little bit
changed my direction but believe me it
you know i i think we all feel if we
take this seriously
i think we all feel that we're as i
think seneca said all patients in the
same hospital
some people have just been here longer
uh so they have more experience dealing
with this disease
of living um i like to look at a little
more positively than that but
that's kind of how i would answer your
question we're all patients in the
hospital and let's just keep trying to
the best we can with this
helpful framework
so please please
um so seneca in a letter to one of his
friends
um his friend first sent him a letter
saying
i've been practicing the stoicism stuff
for a while
i like how it feels i like how
it's affected me but i still get jealous
of people
things still bother me how do i deal
with that
and seneca says um that you
you are better it may not always seem
like you are better um but
a good way to look at it is that you
are suspicious of yourself um you
are recovering in a sense from thinking
of things purely in terms of
um like typical things like
wealth and power and stuff you're you're
moving away from thinking that those are
the most valuable
um and you're not used to that so
anytime that you feel as though
you are um going backwards
you have a feeling like you're over
correcting or that you're not doing
enough or that you're
um you are a pretender in some way
um in my own personal experience i
refuse to
refer to my this is my own experience
i'm not suggesting you do this it's not
really necessary but i refuse to call
myself
a stoic without attaching the practicing
to the the beginning of it as a
practicing stoic because i wanted to say
to myself okay i've had
some rough spots but that there hasn't
been
a huge life event that has really tested
me at
um so um epictetus also reinforces that
with a quote
but i do want to make sure that we get
to other questions
so uh from mark schmidt
asks any interaction and or sorry
any inter intersections between
socialism and other phil's
philosophies that particularly interest
you guys
more than you can imagine i guess
okay um so uh
question for everyone um i guess what
material gaps in stoicism
uh principles and philosophy are there
if any
from the ancient stoicism due to lost
writings or i guess
this is kind of speculation uh from john
smiley
uh this this one is something that i've
struggled with um it's difficult to
it's difficult to understand what isn't
there
like what all has been lost beyond like
specifically book titles
um so um i would say that
it is a huge shame and it is something
that i think about
arguably more than i should um about how
much
material has been lost um we do have
um the the obviously popular titles
um like uh the um
the essays from uh seneca um
uh the anchi meridian things like that
but
as far as like compared to the sheer
amount of volume
of books that used to exist um i would
say that
i do think about hoping that more is
going to get uncovered
um as time goes on
so uh there's not a lot of questions but
there's a conversation
in the chat talking about a women in
stoicism and
i feel like this is a really good topic
to discuss
uh so i can i can start because i was
the one who actually uh opened up that
conversation the chat box so the thing
is that uh
someone called claire i believe uh she
said that
she is on the she visits the subreddit
for
about statism and some folks there say
that woman women
can can't be philosophical and there are
no women's rights which
is just wrong i mean just as i wrote in
the chat box this is probably the best
way to put it it's not just
untrue and insane to say that but it's
also directly contradicting
what the ancient story had to say
because
their message was that everyone
including men women
regardless of gender ethnicity and all
else
can be philosophical and can aspire to
be stoked that was
what that was the part of the original
message and more than that
as far as i know the ancient stokes were
actually the first ones to
say that in the western philosophy so to
say that women cannot be philosophical
is just uh
it's just nonstop so that's
that's a clear answer here and i think
it's important to open this
uh and not not to jump away from women
but just the whole
like modern
at the moment it doesn't fully true but
as far as its face
is is very male and very pale um
it uh we are not uh you know and it's
part of the the history of
why why it came back and who helped
bring it back and such
not totally there there were women
philosophers who very specifically
uh were a big part of bringing virtue
ethics back into the modern movement
um but um that was the face that started
it and
it's really important that as as was
just mentioned
um stoicism itself doesn't not only
doesn't support
it but like emphasizes that all people
uh can participate
um but that doesn't change the fact that
there is a true
it should be a burden on on those of us
that that get to talk
and such to find and to promote
um others that aren't the exactly the
same
with us in some sort of cultural or or
uh or gender or
you know a sense because um because that
requires effort
right um it requires effort to make sure
that
all voices are being heard and expressed
and if we really want
a blossoming of stoicism that reaches
all
people um it takes a concerted effort on
the part of those
that have uh have a way to speak uh to
do that
and and that's that's a i i see movement
towards that but it still
is a failing that i think we need to
acknowledge
um can i also add a small point which is
i just wanted to say that i think a lot
of this is driven by social
media and our current situation where
there's this
anonymity on these social media
platforms that i think
and i put this in the chat i mean i
think it allows certain people who
for their own personal gratification
find it fun to be
trolls and to basically just uh try to
suppress other people's voices because
they feel like it because it makes them
feel powerful it makes them feel cool
this is very bad i mean in the large
stoic
facebook groups um i mean i've seen
several women just stop posting because
they don't want to be attacked for who
they are for their identity the whole
point of this philosophy is that
we're you know we can all find the sense
of reason
inside us question our impressions and
question
even the sensory data around us that
tells us that person's a woman
that person's a man that person is this
race that person is that race or that
i think to me a lot of the benefit of
stoicism is
able to question judging someone
based on externals that person's rich
that person is
you know and so on and i think we we
totally lose that on the internet
we have these groups where it's almost
like self
perpetuating judgment and rage
and because of our social media
platforms the engagement goes up
the algorithm says this is this is more
interesting to people and that's what
gets focused on
and i think that these platforms have
have a lot to answer for
personally and of course these
individuals who rely on the
high behind the anonymity of the
internet to really
say mean and hateful things to women
especially but into any people people of
color
they they don't want to understand the
virtues they don't care about that
they're using this as a self-empowering
but that's meant to push down other
people and
i'd love to see more people stand up to
them in addition to women because
when women do they're just like again
push down like oh well you know women
can't be philosophical why
women are emotional that's why they're
saying this to me so i feel as if
there's we all have a responsibility to
do as much as we can to fight this
oh absolutely please please um i think
meredith threw down a gauntlet so that's
good i
i picked up the very similar gauntlet
two years ago and donna zuckerberg made
it exact point
uh that in the stories that were totally
an obstacle is the way
it was like all people of qualities in
american expression were either in
prison
or in some way travel in the law there
was not a celebration of
people come in a different way an
obstacle is the way i that's not a
criticism towards ryan holiday but it
was
like how can i show that fact that xena
was an immigrant
he wasn't white it's not they say it's
white they've mentioned it wasn't white
glianfest was an immigrant spherus was
from ukraine
so in the book uh being better i
actually told the stories
of stories that don't often get talked
about
so in the story i was saying about
spirits and sparta
it is adi artists the spartan queen
i can't i went to all her story because
i was wouldn't want to read the chapter
who actually encourages um her two
husbands actually because one gets
murdered
to to embrace some historic kind of
principles
so i would say that anybody who says
that there's no women in terrorism
hasn't done an ounce of homework they
haven't done it and as murdered before
they're not trying to understand
terrorism they're just trying to make a
lot of noise
um i think you're absolutely right that
we have to stand up as a community
together and not leave it to women to
say something
i also think that because of the
popularized
versions of stories and put it like that
we haven't given space to him because
already it's all great saying yeah let's
give them a microphone
when they're not even given the space to
be able to hold the microphone
so i felt like by telling ideas story
that would give an opportunity because
it's not good enough for me to go yeah
but of course we give the microphone to
them
they just have to come up here and
request it and do all the hard work and
then oh yeah i'll hand over the
microphone i'm ignored if you're smiling
because you know what i'm saying
so i think it's not it's just not enough
for us to you know
to give a microphone it's to say look
this is this is the reality and this is
the space
and then if you want the microphone you
can have it because that's the other
thing it's like
there's also i often feel like this
christian goes two ways like oh because
women aren't
i've heard it well we want women here
but they don't want to stand up it's
like it doesn't work that way when
you're
when you're on the outside of a
friendship group it's not for you to
push your way through
you can't it's for the people on the
inside to open up the circle
the circles of concern this direct case
right i think on one level
it's like yes we know there's a problem
but i don't think that
some of the efforts that i've seen have
been the way that women would
i mean i don't want to speak for women
but women tend to like to approach
things they like to be invited not
forced away because the minute they
unfortunately raise their voice see
that's the problem
that's exactly why we don't have women
so it's difficult it's a chicken and egg
thing
and i think it's really great that
meredith is is here to prove a point
that
not only can you be a stroke you can be
you can be a leading
modern stomach and say actually i have
something to say but i would say that
meredith has had to do jump over
obstacles that we need to remove as a
community
and it doesn't always need to mean that
i go around
slacking people on like uh social media
i thought the best way to make a
statement was to
work with people like red lopez to
create you know
the books in the way that i wanted to to
say okay you you believe that
where's the where's your homework so i
kind of felt like i should do the
homework because that's my role
as an academic so other people didn't so
again it goes back to what greg said
about
knowing your role i don't know meredith
i don't want to talk of you am i am i
right and what i said
i think you're 100 right because the
fear is you raise your voice and then
someone just judges you accuses you
and i've seen it happen a lot online i
personally haven't had a chance to do as
many in-person events
because of you know my busy life with
work and family
but so i'm mostly primarily interact
with people online and
i am very wary of posting on the main
modern stoicism group on facebook right
now i mean
i haven't personally had a lot of
problems but i've witnessed a lot of
things that truly bothered me
and um i i would love if we also include
women's
experiences a little bit more and that's
part of the reason why i talk a lot
about parenting
and also about women in the workplace
and
women role models um i've written a
piece about ruth bader ginsburg on my
blog it's
the top post right now on there i mean
the the one you'll see if you go to my
blog the stoic mom because i think
um that's another thing we're still
lacking in our society as well women
role models who
are you know expressing this they may
not be quote stoic because they didn't
adopt stoic life philosophy but they
express a lot of this kind of leadership
that i think
uh we want to see and that women really
can
and men can all appreciate shows that
women are equals to men
intellectually we we we all acknowledge
that but i think there are a lot of
people out there who
just use this um you know brotherism to
be
kind of this very macho manly and you
know there's this whole culture of
backlash against feminism that we're
also
dealing with um because women who speak
out are oh well
she's just doing that because she's
feminist and
she wants all men to you know be
you know beneath her or something so
there's a lot of very misguided ideas
out there and so um i thank you for
you know inviting me and including me i
think we can do more there are
some women in stoicism who are very
prominent and i think we can also just
encourage
more people we have to find a space
though i think this idea of what are the
spaces
if anyone has more thoughts on that
because every time we open up a space
online we're having some of these issues
i would say the stoic parents
group is a closed group you have to
request it
we have a lot better success there with
less trolling and we try to control if
something happens like that but
thinking about what kind of spaces could
be successful and and also bringing in
you know all kinds of people people of
color people of different backgrounds
different socioeconomic groups who can
be interested in this
um and can benefit how can we be
inclusive
so i love this topic but i also want to
get to a couple more questions
so uh next question here is from claire
how can we best apply stoicism in our
romantic relationships
i can do it that's a really tough
question
did you want to did you want to go up
the other no no go ahead
okay um so just like everything in life
um stoic said that there's a role um
that you have to play
by trying to understand or think about
whatever role it is that you're
referencing um you
are generally speaking able to
form guidelines for how you should
behave or what
is meant to be considered important
and whatever the context is um in this
context it would be
uh boyfriend girlfriend uh spouse
um partner that type of thing um in
which case
uh you would want to think of it
in addition as what your overarching
role
as a social and rational animal is so
combined
combining the two means that you are to
support them if they're having
difficulties emotionally
physically mentally you
are to try to support them as best as
you can
without overstepping and and
accepting that what is happening
to them or to you and directly
constitutes a bad thing um the way that
it appears
or if something really amazing happens
um
on on a surface level uh like a
you know congrats you want a new car
things like that
of um supporting the person
in their in their enjoyment of the thing
keeping in the back of your mind that it
is temporary
um that you are able to enjoy it for the
time that you have it and so on
um but that it's not necessarily
a constitutes a good thing in in terms
of stoic philosophy
um taking out the trash doing chores
um teaching your children
um those types of things uh basically
what you imagine a good partner would do
is what is encouraged
in that given role and that extends your
overarching role as a stoic
oh if i if i may just uh add one uh once
more point uh i once like
five or six years ago i gave an
interview and the title was
um someone kind of uh
thought about the title that love is not
a noun
it is a verb and i think it's a very
good point here
in the sense that um whatever your
relationship
is and whatever configuration you're
talking about
uh the stoic approach would be or should
be
uh that we are not uh that that we are
seeing love or
friendship or romantic involvement or
parenting whatever
uh as a um as the as the ability
capacity and willingness to do certain
to to
uh to give certain attitude to do
uh certain types of of things
regardless of uh circumstances
circumstances time place mood and so on
and so this kind of
constant disposition to do things toward
a certain person in a certain manner and
that would be a
fair point here i believe and of course
if the other person
gives that has the same point of view
that would be that would be helpful i
think
and also from the chat here greg and
andy do a number of these types of
work on talking about relationships and
we'll have the link to that
linked with this video
um a quick question for uh matt um
where did you go uh he's asking
[Music]
um
i'm going to go back to that um i was
wondering about the ideas
of a stoic action and where
um you can see that both within these
communities that we are making within
the modern statuses
movement and in the greater world around
us
and that's the general question to
everybody not specifically to me right
yeah that is a general question sorry
but uh uh
someone muted um uh
can you rephrase the very last part of
the question there
concerning stoic action
um especially within our communities
how can we uh go around and uh
what are the actions in a stoke sense
that we should be taking in order to
uh make them i guess uh more beneficial
for all people
yeah um well i think that that's one of
the
important um an important emphasis we
need to have
in modern stoicism is is that engagement
uh with our with our community um and
a lot of the a lot of the problems i see
online
people are talking about they're very in
their own head and uh which is
understandable still systems
happening up here but um but socialism
is about
uh a an interaction and an embrace
of the world and the people around us
right so
um whatever
whatever you're interested in you're
really uh whatever you're interested in
um or concerned with uh in your in your
community whether that's uh
people you actually get to meet or
whether it's your you know i'm
looking around my neighborhood
find engagement right uh just uh you
know whether it's a group
um uh there's a uh there's a warming
shelter
uh that that that i helped support
uh here in my in my area and such
um you know something something that
concerns you um
you can do that stoically right like uh
just by participating in your community
and and one of the important things of
that is is that
when you're dealing with people who are
not coming at you from a
lens they're just you know living their
lives have different beliefs
and such uh the real challenge is is
actually living out virtue um
uh with that difference right
is to uh is to embrace people as fully
as you can
and and to and to come alongside them
and to help them as best you can
while doing that as a stoic i mean it's
a you know that
i mean it's the whole that's the whole
life challenge
thank you so we're coming to the end
here so it's any um last thoughts about
uh this question or anything else yeah i
just wanted to follow up on something
that was said in the chat about somebody
from west virginia was having trouble
finding local meetings um i saw greg
sadler put a mention to the stoic
fellowship but i just wanted to expand
on that a little
greg did say that a lot of meetings are
being held online now and that's true
new york city stoix is on the line as
well we're all having a meeting tomorrow
actually on
uh cicero's on duties book one so
um but we also have opened up in the
stoic fellowship a bunch of
um online only groups that you can see
by the wi-fi symbol and salmon pin
so if you go to our main page you'll see
a map of all the stoic groups and those
are going to be online only for the
foreseeable future so
find something in your time zone click a
couple that sound interesting to you and
see if you can join up
and that's my advice for that
uh okay um thank you all for uh coming
on uh
i guess really quick where can people
find you on peter
on the internets uh
that's a tricky question because i have
a facebook page but
it is in polish which makes it difficult
probably
i'll put in the link in the chat right
away thanks for
information uh greg
uh yeah i'm i'm not super on social
media i do have a personal webpage at
greg lopez.me dot
me and you can contact me there and i am
on twitter though i rarely post i'm
trying to post maybe slightly more you
could find me at uh
g lopez farm d mattbanetta
uh my website's a moderatestoic.com
though the easiest way if you want to
have any form of direct engagement with
me would be on twitter
good fortune cast for podcast good
fortune cast
is my twitter uh handle and drives hume
sorry i messed with my mute button again
uh the main applying socialism group um
can be found on facebook.com
forward slash groups forward slash
applying socialism it's open to view and
join
the majority of my writing over the last
seven years can be found at applying
stoicism.com
thank you uh meredith coons
guns yes hi there hi um you can check
out my blog
at thestoicmom.com um i'm on twitter at
the stoic woman
uh i'd like to do a little bit more with
that but i am there so please follow me
and
we have the stoic parents group on
facebook by request
please request if you're interested to
join that group
i'm one of the admins and kai wedding
um you can give me on storyki.com or
at kaiwei on twitter or you can like
literally just bother me on facebook if
you put
like i'm really one of those i guess
facebook people that like to
talk and make sure that there's not so
many trolls so yeah basically if you
type my name in i normally respond to
you
within like 24 hours i'm quite active on
there for
because i i take what meredith says
seriously so there's
multiple ways you can get older it's
really not that difficult
thank you all for coming to this uh
incredible uh experts panel
uh if can i just say one more thing here
uh thank you for
all the questions and they were kind of
uh inspiring to me in the way that uh
and the discussion about women and
feminism it kind of
shows how statism in my in my view it
shows how statism is alive in the sense
it's kind of
trying to deal with the new challenges
and trying to
uh you know talk to the new uh new
problems that
we are all facing in our life in 2020
the pandemic the the question of women
and so on so
great questions thanks guys thank you
you